the wedding proposal no big deal right  just the most important question you'll  ever ask someone and my buddy Matt he  decided to it on vacation well he's  going to be fine and it's going to be  amazing because today we're coming to  you from American Express studios where  we're going to share the smartest ways  to nail that vacation I was packing the  ring of the carry out means that it  won't potentially get lost with the  check bag or worse fall out of your  pocket when we sit down dude hotel  concierge ascend restaurant managers  arrange stuff like this all the time  like having champagne ready to pop up so  embrace your local resources X make sure  you have a lay of the land so your  proposal story doesn't evolve you to  getting lost and remember those  important moments I really spilled  coffee on our the first day save the  complex planning for your wedding and  let this part that journey be magical  got a friend who's ready to propose tag  him in the comments